(Musique du générique...)
[Sky] : David Koubbi, bonjour !
Bonjour !
[Sky] : Nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne Youtube
[Sky] : qui s'appelle Thinkerview.
[Sky] : Précaution oratoire comme d'habitude : tu es mon avocat donc je vais te tutoyer
pendant cette interview.
[Sky] : On te reçoit aujourd'hui à la suite du jugement
[Sky] : Société Générale versus Jérôme Kerviel.
[Sky] : Qu'est-ce que tu peux nous en dire ?
[Sky] : Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
[Sky] : Quels sont les résultats ?
[Sky] : Explique-nous.
Écoute... c'est assez simple :
ce n'est pas l'histoire qu'on nous avait racontée
depuis 9 années !
Tu connais Jérôme Kerviel comme étant
ce trader voyou, c'était comme ça qu'il avait été décrit,
pour avoir été responsable d'une perte, dont personne n'a prouvé qu'elle existait,
qui s'élevait à 4,9 milliards d'euros.
Et, maintenant que la justice est passée, et qu'elle est bien passée,
il est responsable à 0,02 % de ces 4,9 milliards d'euros
d'après la justice française. Donc...
en face de cela nous avons
Société Générale qui est une
honorable banque qui, elle, est
responsable arithmétiquement à
hauteur de 99,98 %.
Mais,
à ce stade là de notre entretien, ce que
j'ai envie de te dire c'est que
dans l'esprit des journalistes et dans l'esprit des politiques, Société Générale c'est un
monolithe.
Personne ne se demande qui est derrière
Société Générale. On te dit
Kerviel d'un côté et
Société Générale de l'autre
et tout le monde semble se satisfaire de ça.
Nous, nous ne nous satisfaisons pas de ça
et on est en train de regarder
qui est derrière Société Générale.
[Sky] : Qui est derrière Société Générale ?
Eh bien ses dirigeants ! Enfin, tu vois.
C'est assez simple :
il y a une ligne hiérarchique.
Il se trouve que toute la ligne hiérarchique de Jérôme Kerviel a été payée et ça,
c'est acquis au débat.
Ce sont des pièces
que nous avons dans le dossier même si...
[Sky] : Qui étaient payés de leur salaire ? Leur responsabilité ?
Non mais écoute : que des gens soient payés de leur salaire
je trouve ça plutôt sain, dans la
société qui est la nôtre,
en revanche d'être payés 7 ans de
salaire fixe,
7 : c'est-à-dire 5+2,
quand on est licencié pour insuffisance
professionnelle ça commence à
poser une question, qui est une question philosophique
et qui s'apparente au prix du silence !
Donc tu as un opérateur qu'on a
voulu isoler et on y reviendra.
Il y a un mobile à cette volonté de
l'isoler. Et en tout cas, il y a
une conséquence à ça : c'est que ça a
permis à la banque d'obtenir
2,2 milliards d'euros d'argent public
donc l'impôt des français, hein,
en violation de la jurisprudence du
Conseil d'État qui était alors en vigueur.
Et notamment un arrêt pour
les spécialistes, parce que c'est un dossier où il y a beaucoup de spécialistes,
donc pour les spécialistes qui nous regardent, un arrêt Alcatel CIT
du 5 octobre 2007
qui pose des conditions qui, en l'espèce,
c'est-à-dire au cas qui nous occupe,
n'étaient pas remplies, ne permettant
ainsi pas à Société Générale de percevoir cet argent.
Donc on a là ce que je vois comme étant un mobile
pour que Société Générale perçoive
cet argent et ça s'apparente à un siphonnage.
J'ai eu l'occasion en 2012 de dire
déjà que
cela me faisait penser aux plus
grands casses du siècle donc
de cette affaire, qui était
une affaire
quasiment un fait divers, même si
c'était un fait divers planétaire,
on passe à une affaire indéniablement d'État.
[Sky] : Le ministre des Finances, est-ce que tu as eu des contacts avec lui ?
[Sky] : Est-ce que tu as été contacté par Bercy ?
[Sky] : Est-ce que des associations de la société civile t'ont demandé si la Société Générale allait pouvoir rembourser ?
[Sky] : Ou est-ce que la Société Générale doit / ne doit pas (rembourser) ?
[Sky] : Est-ce que la Société Générale a
suffisamment de fonds propres pour pouvoir rembourser ?
Alors le ministre Michel Sapin,
parce qu'il faut nommer les gens, hein,
on a déjà eu cette conversation toi et moi...
[Sky] : Ici on est sur Thinkerview : il faut donner des noms hein !
Mais oui c'est ça ! Parce que si tu nommes pas, ça devient l'institution,
et l'institution c'est personne. C'est comme Société Générale :
Société Générale c'est personne : c'est tout le monde et c'est personne !
Donc le ministre Michel Sapin, à la
disposition duquel nous avons indiqué nous tenir,
n'a pas jugé opportun, ni de
nous recevoir,
ni d'adresser quelque message en notre direction que ce soit.
Ni lui, alors qu'on s'attend pas à ce qu'un ministre appelle.
Faut pas
déconner non plus !
Mais ni lui, ni quiconque de son
administration. Ça c'est pour répondre à ta première question.
Les fonds propres de Société
Générale c'est pas mon sujet.
Je ne suis pas l'avocat de Société
Générale.
On sait simplement que leurs comptes sont faux.
On le sait parce que leur avocat l'a dit
à l'audience.
Il a lâché ça de manière exaspérée
en disant "les comptes de Société Générale sont faux !".
[Sky] : C'était de l'ironie peut-être, non?
Non, non, non, c'était tout à fait juste.
Sa théorie c'est que
Jérôme kerviel, ayant
fait des manœuvres frauduleuses,
a conduit Société Générale à
présenter aux marchés des comptes faux.
Donc ça dans la vraie vie, c'est-à-dire la vie où il y a un droit applicable,
c'est répréhensible.
Mais pas pour Société Générale parce que quand c'est Société Générale
c'est pas grave ! Donc je te redis, les fonds propres de la banque
c'est pas notre sujet, et est-ce que
Société Générale doit ou ne doit pas :
bien sûr qu'elle le doit,
bien sûr qu'elle doit cet argent, puisqu'elle n'aurait jamais dû,
juridiquement,
le percevoir !
[Sky] : Alors comment ça se fait qu'ils ont
toujours pas remboursé ?
Mais c'est à l'étude, on est en train de t'indiquer du côté de Bercy que
"Les services de l'État" te dit Michel Sapin...
Tu noteras que quand  Michel Sapin parle de l'État,
il se montre comme ça, à lui-même !
... "Les services de l'état sont en train de regarder"
Mais Michel Sapin oublie quelque chose c'est que
sous l'empire de son prédécesseur,
Pierre Moscovici, en 2012,
nous avons d'ores et déjà des traces au dossier pénal,
traces au terme desquelles
la DVNI, qui est une division spéciale des impôts, de Bercy, était déjà en train de
s'interroger sur le caractère
déductible ou non déductible de la perte,
qu'il était coutume alors d'appeler
"perte Kerviel".
Gageons que si cette étude nous avait été défavorable,
si cette enquête nous avait été défavorable,
elle serait sortie publiquement.
Mais de toute façon les choses sont claires :
il y a une jurisprudence
du Conseil d'État. Il n'y a rien
au-dessus du Conseil d'État dans
l'ordre judiciaire administratif.
Et en application de cette jurisprudence,
ils ne devaient pas percevoir cet
argent.
Depuis lors le droit a encore avancé en
mars 2014 puisque
la cour de cassation
a décidé de revenir sur
la répartition entre
Jérôme Kerviel et Société Générale de
ces 4,9 milliards
renvoyant à la cour d'appel de
Versailles. Tu m'avais reçu d'ailleurs
peu avant le mois de juin, alors que nous plaidions là-bas,
et maintenant nous avons un résultat
qui est définitif qui laisse
1 million d'euros à la charge de Jérôme Kerviel
et 4,9 milliards moins 1 million à la charge de Société Générale !
C'est ça ce calcul : 0,02 %
de responsabilité pour
Jérôme Kerviel
et 99,98 % pour Société Générale.
Donc là le débat semble clos
si on regarde les choses en légaliste,
mais c'est pas comme ça que c'est regardé.
[Sky] : Quand on a entendu parler de la
condamnation à 1 million d'euros,
[Sky] : elle a été formulée de telle façon
[Sky] : par la justice comme une peine à hauteur d'homme...
Ouais.
[Sky] : Qu'est-ce que t'en penses ?
Hum...
Écoutes...
Qu'est-ce que j'en pense...
Euh...
J'en pense que tout ce qui fait que l'opinion, la presse, un certain nombre
d'activistes de nos amis...
Je ne t'ai pas répondu sur les
associations, tout à l'heure, de
contribuables, donc la réponse pour
l'expurger est
oui. Nous sommes en
contact des associations qui manient
parfaitement bien le corpus
juridique fiscal
et qui ont compris qu'il convenait
de recouvrer donc
notre travail est d'avancer avec
eux et de voir comment on peut permettre
à la collectivité nationale de récupérer
l'argent qui lui revient.
[Sky] : Surtout en ce moment !
Oui, puisque il paraît qu'on est serré, il paraît qu'on est dans une crise
économique, hein ! Tu connais toute cette théorie de
"c'est la crise économique donc tenez vous tranquille c'est la crise !"
[Sky] : Ouais, l'austérité, ouais
à la réalité on n'est pas en crise
économique mais ça c'est autre chose.
Pour revenir à ta question,
j'en pense que je j'ai
l'honneur de défendre
un citoyen français, Jérôme Kerviel, qui est condamné à 1 millions d'euros,
alors que ça fait neuf ans qu'il vit
avec au-dessus de la tête
une somme faramineuse de près de 5
milliards
qui là, pour la peine, n'est pas à hauteur d'homme,
et qu'il est condamné dans un
dispositif
où tous les opérateurs,
les chevilles ouvrières de ce dossier,
je pense à l'officier de police judiciaire
Nathalie Le Roy qu'on avait déjà eu
l'occasion d'évoquer,
et à la procureure Chantal de Leiris, toutes deux en charge du dossier,
disent ensemble que le dossier a été truqué
avec des complicités au sein
du parquet de Paris !
[Sky] : C'est grave, hein ! C'est grave comme accusation hein !
Oui moi, je le sais...
C'est pas une accusation, c'est un fait !
C'est-à-dire que ces gens-là nous disent des choses...
[Sky] : Vous avez des preuves?
... et c'est  un point de confort... Mais bien sûr !
[Sky] : Quelles preuves ?
Évidemment !
Ben les témoignages de ces personnes-là !
[Sky] : D'accord.
Qui sont, à soi seules, des preuves.
Et quand nous on vous disait ça
à l'époque vous pouviez vous dire :
"Oui bon bah l'avocat de Kerviel
est en train de turbuler, il est en train de faire je sais pas quoi, de la presse ou...
il fait le malin, ou...
[Sky] :  du théâtre
Oui ! Oui ! Ou de la politique, ou enfin tu vois : on nous a collé tout un tas de machins,
mais maintenant c'est plus nous qui le disons :
c'est les gens
qui ont fourni le travail de base
ayant permis la condamnation de Jérôme Kerviel.
Donc ça devient un autre dossier.
Et dans ce contexte-là, on a vécu en juin une audience un peu particulière,
où il y avait les avocats de Société Générale que
j'avais fait citer à comparaître
in personam : eux personnellement puisqu'ils sont
mentionnés dans les fameux enregistrements
de la policière sur la procureure de la République...
[Sky] : Enregistrements... dixit frauduleux ou sans l'accord, c'est ça ?
D'après ce qui nous est présenté, sans
l'accord
de l'un des intéressés mais ça
demeure une information.
C'est-à-dire que... Actuellement dans...
[Sky] : Dans le pénal c'est recevable ce type d'enregistrement ?
Oui complètement. On a une jurisprudence Bettencourt
sur le sujet. Et si tu veux on doit
arbitrer entre
une éventuelle violation de la vie
privée d'un côté, et le mandat qui
m'est donné en tant qu'avocat
d'avoir à faire mon travail.
Donc j'ai opté pour
l'option qui ne semblait la plus
saine,
c'est-à-dire faire mon travail !
Donc moi on me remet un élément dans ma main, là, ici,
au terme duquel le procès est truqué.
Et je dois en tant qu'homme, en tant
qu'avocat décider si j'utilise
cet élément ou si j'écrase le
coup.
[Sky] : En ton âme et conscience.
Oui. Mais il n'y a pas de match :
tu fais le travail. Voilà.
Donc,
dans ce contexte-là :
cette audience un peu particulière où
il y avait les avocats de Société Générale,
mis en cause personnellement,
le parquet, qui est une des
parties au procès pénal,
et la juridiction
où on fait jouer des enregistrements pendant cette audience
indiquant que le parquet
s'est compromis
dans le traitement judiciaire de ce dossier.
Alors évidemment, ça, ça fait des tâches sur les murs, tu vois,
parce qu'il ne faut pas dire ça normalement.
Ce qui est attendu de nous tous,
c'est que (si) l'un d'entre vous, vous justiciables,
moi je suis un justiciable aussi, mais l'un d'entre vous
est dans cette situation, eh bien on doit laisser filer.
Bon, c'est pas comme ça que les avocats de mon cabinet et moi-même l'avons entendu.
Et donc on a décidé d'amener ce débat
jusqu'au bout, avec une particularité que je trouve absolument fascinante :
c'est que personne, à date, ne s'est inquiété de savoir ce qu'il y avait dans ces enregistrements.
Au-delà des quelques passages que j'ai pris la décision stratégique de révéler,
personne ne nous demande ces enregistrements.
[Sky] : La presse, la presse n'a pas bougé ? Le Canard Enchaîné ? Mediapart ?
Non, non, non : personne.
[Sky] : Personne !
Mediapart a fait des articles, la presse a fait des articles, enfin la presse ça veut rien dire tu sais bien mais...
Certains médias on fait des articles,
mais moi je ne te parle pas de presse, je te parle d'une exploitation, euh...
[Sky] : judiciaire
par la justice !
C'est-à-dire que si je viens chez toi en te disant ton machin est truqué,
ben tu as soit intérêt à couvrir tes troupes,
soit intérêt à dire : "ah bon, ben montrez-moi les éléments et je vais statuer."
Et donc là, que ce soit le doyen des juges d'instructions, qui est en charge d'un certains nombres de dossiers, Roger Le Loire,
que ce soit le parquet de Paris,
J'ai personnellement avisé François Molins [procureur de Paris] de l'existence de ces enregistrements,
que ce soit le bâtonnier de Paris, puisqu'il s'agit d'avocats,
donc il n'est pas complètement inepte que l'un de ces 3 corps se saisisse du sujet,
que ce soient les magistrats du siège,
on décide de ne pas regarder se disant que : "Ça va nous passer", tu vois !
"Puisqu'on nous demande pas, on devrait, peut-être penser à autre chose au bout d'un moment
ou oublier que nous avons ça !"
C'est absurde !
[Sky] : J'ai vu que le dossier était en train être déporté à Lille.
[Sky] : Raconte-moi un peu cette déportation à Lille.
Alors, hum...
C'est pas le dossier principal qui est dépaysé à Lille.
C'est le dossier qui se met à exister par une plainte de la fameuse procureure de la République Chantal de Leiris
contre le commandant de police Nathalie Le Roy, qu'elle rencontre,
avec laquelle elle parle librement, donc on entend ce qu'elle dit quand elle parle librement,
et c'est très intéressant de l'entendre,
et à la réalité nous avons exploité 12 ou 13 petits extraits
sur 35 minutes d'enregistrement utile,
donc à ceux qui te regarderaient, et notamment mes adversaires, et qui sont en train de se demander
si on a mis la gomme sur les premiers éléments, ou si on a attendu
décidant de garder le meilleur pour plus tard, eh bien
je les laisse comme il est dit dans La Chute de Camus "coucher avec le mystère".
Je pense que tu as la réponse à la question que je pose
et que eux aussi, hein, je dis ça ironiquement mais...
Cette procureur a pris la décision de déposer plainte contre Nathalie Le Roy,
commandant Nathalie Le Roy,
pour violation de la vie privée,
et, a priori, mais nous ne savons pas où est cette plainte aujourd'hui
et personne n'a jugé opportun, même en terme de confraternité de nous l'adresser,
contre Jérôme Kerviel et contre moi-même, en qualité de receleur.
Et finalement, l'ironie du sujet
et je trouve ça assez incroyable, mais pourquoi pas,
c'est que la façon dont ce sujet va rentrer
dans le système judiciaire
se produit au travers d'une plainte dirigée contre nous !
C'est-à-dire que les gens qui sont en train de se débattre en disant : "ça fait 9 ans qu'on vous dit qu'un dossier est truqué.",
"Voilà les éléments dont nous disposons.",
eh bien la justice va se saisir des ces éléments-là, au travers d'une plainte qui est dirigée et déposée contre nous !
Alors, moi j'ai à remercier nos adversaires de nous offrir ce théâtre d'opérations,
puisque comme je te le disais auparavant, sans cela,
la justice ne s'en saisissait pas !
Donc on va attendre sereinement, et tranquillement, de pouvoir aller discuter du fond,
parce que la forme c'est très important, hein, on l'a vu encore cette semaine avec l'intervention de Jérôme Kerviel,
et peut-être m'interrogerais-tu, là-dessus, à un moment ou à un autre, en face d'Alain Juppé, donc...
Tu vois, les internautes, les réseaux sociaux, se sont fait les échos
de cette forme en disant "Mais comment ça ?!" etc.
Mais le fond, ça n'intéresse jamais personne !
[Sky] : Tu parles de Juppé... Juppé ou les autres politiques qu'est-ce qu'ils en disent ? Qu'est-ce qu'ils en pensent ?
[Sky] : Quelle sont leur connaissance du dossier ?
[Sky] : Est-ce qu'ils ont la moindre idée comment fonctionnent les choses
[Sky] : ou ils sont, on va dire, euh... avec un regard de dandy ?
Alors c'est compliqué de te répondre d'une manière, euh..., de façon  générale,
parce qu'il existe des politiques qui ont très largement
contribué à enlever le dossier de l'ornière dans laquelle...
[Sky] : Lesquels?
Le sénateur communiste Éric Bocquet, Jean-Luc Mélenchon, Eva Joly, Julien Bayou (Europe Écologie Les Verts),
le député républicain Georges Fenech, ancien magistrat,
co-auteur de la réforme avec le député socialiste Alain Tourret sur la révision pénale,
Éric Alauzet,
Marie-Noëlle Lienemann au PS,
Jérôme Guedj, l'ancien ministre Benoist Apparu,
Édouard Philippe soutien d'Alain Juppé,
François Bayrou, un temps, tu vois, donc il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont...
Nicolas Dupont Aignan qu'on est parti remercier à son congrès, ça aussi ça a été "Oh là là mon Dieu !",
tu vois...
Ces gens-là ont contribué à déplanter le dossier.
Mais ces gens-là ne sont pas au pouvoir.
Et ce qui m'intéresse c'est de voir l'espèce d'inertie
qui existe au pouvoir
et, qu'on parle d'une
présidence Sarkozy ou d'une présidence Hollande,
et puis on a compris
dans cet échange Jérôme Kerviel/Alain Juppé
que si Alain Juppé devait être
Président de la République ça ne
serait pas
son sujet de prédilection
puisque ce n'est pas avec une langue en
bois
qu'on décrit le mieux
les problématiques du pays.
C'est en nommant les choses et en
apportant des solutions et c'est pas ça,
c'est pas ce à quoi nous avons
assisté lors de ce débat,
lors de cet échange.
[Sky] : T'as assisté à quoi?
J'ai assisté à un Jérôme
Kerviel
à bout de souffle parce que
parce que 9 années de
combats laissent des traces.
Et la vie qui va avec est une vie qui
est compliquée
pour lui, incidemment pour moi, pour d'autres.
Ce Jérôme Kerviel là
disait de son mieux à Alain Juppé
la façon dont il voyait les choses.
Et Alain Juppé répondait avec
une espèce de satisfaction affichée
sur ce que "on a fait", disait-il,
alors que je je n'ai pas compris qu'il
gouvernait entre entre 2008 et aujourd'hui 2016.
Mais sur ce qu'"on" a fait disait-il,
il était Premier ministre avant hein, pas pendant ces années-là,
pour réguler le système bancaire, et
nous, nous considérons avec d'autres :
avec
avec les gens d'ATTAC, avec un
certain nombre
de personnes très impliquées dans des milieux
associatifs
et/ou activistes,
et tu sais que je n'ai aucune
difficulté pour discuter
avec ces hommes politiques
"mainstream"
ou pour aller me perdre
auprès d'autres soutiens et
d'autres personnes qui peuvent
apporter à la cause que je sers.
Il disait que
grosso-modo "'on a fait beaucoup de choses depuis la crise de 2008"
et puis, s'agissant du
reste,
il a une vision très légaliste
des choses quand il s'agit de
NE PAS condamner
la façon dont le système bancaire est
dévoyé
[Sky] : Tu lui as parlé de la séparation des
banques d'affaires et des banques de détail ?
Non, ce n'était pas le sujet.
Ce n'était pas le sujet
pendant ce débat.
Mais on voit quelle est la position,
et on voit surtout que
rien ne ressemble plus à un ancien
inspecteur des finances
qu'un autre inspecteur des finances.
On a un sujet de club ici tu comprends ?
Un sujet de club.
Ça aussi ça va être beaucoup
critiqué.
Parce qu'il ne faut pas dire dans ce dossier
qu'il y a un pacte de place :
ça les insulte !
[Sky] : C'est interdit ? C'est tabou ?
Euh...
Les gens comme toi et moi on est insulté quand on est insulté.
Eux, je ne parle pas d'Alain Juppé, je parle de cette caste dirigeante,
ils sont insultés alors qu'ils sont
décrits !
Décrits comme ils sont !
Tu vois, il existe des clubs aujourd'hui
où tu n'entres pas, je n'entre pas, Kerviel n'entre pas,
les petits contribuables n'entrent pas
et où un certain nombre de décisions sont
prises et discutées. [Sky] : Dans les salons feutrés oui...
[Sky] : On arrive aux élections
présidentielles. Est-ce que tu es pour
[Sky] : ou contre le fait que
[Sky] : ceux voulant accéder à, ceux voulant
[Sky] : prétendre à la plus haute fonction de
l'État aient un casier judiciaire vierge ?
Oui tu connais ma
position
sur le sujet : je
ne conçois pas un instant
qu'il puisse en être
autrement !
Je ne conçois pas qu'on ait pu
avoir quoi que ce soit affaire avec des deniers publics,
quoi que ce soit à faire d'illégal
avec des deniers publics sans que
cela laisse des traces qui soient durables et
coercitives.
Et, et d'une manière générale, nous
réfléchissions avec un certain nombre d'amis
aux conditions qui pourraient
permettre à un con comme moi de revoter par exemple
puisque tu sais que je ne vote pas
je n'ai jamais voté
et en fait, moi, ce qu'il me faudrait,
là,
sur notre table, dans notre table commune, sur notre table nationale,
ça serait un dispositif légal,
donc une loi,
et nous entendons interroger
les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle sur ce sujet,
une loi prévoyant que, lorsqu'un élu de
la République, un fonctionnaire, hein,
est pris la main dans le
sac en train de détourner des fonds publics,
on veut :
1 - qu'il soit inéligible à vie,
alors je connais les petits verrous juridiques qu'il faudra faire sauter pour obtenir ça,
il y aura un débat d'experts
parce que (pour) chaque notion il y a ses experts, ça c'est très intéressant,
inéligibles à vie et que la
collectivité nationale leur prenne tout.
Alors "tout" on te dira que j'ai une
vision très
radicale du sujet, et j'assume cette
vision radicale,
mais si on veut quelque chose d'un peu plus édulcoré, parce que tu sais on est en 2016 donc
il faut que les choses soient un peu
[Sky] : lissées
doucereuses comme ça et lissées,
voilà, sans faire trop de vagues, on peut
envisager que la somme qui sera prise
par la collectivité nationale à ce
genre d'élus
qui se seront dévoyés,
sera la somme la plus élevée entre
ce qu'ils ont perçu depuis le début
de leur carrière politique
en termes de salaires, traitements et
défraiements,
et/ou la somme qu'ils ont
détournée.
Et ça, ça permettrait de revoter, tu
vois
c'est-à-dire que quand on parle de la
restauration de la confiance dans la vie
politique
il faut pas que ça soit de la
parlotte, il faut pas que ce soient des
mots.
[Sky] : Il faut que ce soit ferme.
Ben oui, parce que tu ne peux pas expliquer à nos
concitoyens tout à la fois que
une loi est fabriquée, qu'elle est dure,
quelle est inévitable, qu'elle
s'applique en toute circonstance, sauf
quand il s'agit des ministres !
[Sky] : La fameuse justice à deux vitesses ? La justice entre potes ?
Ben oui, écoute.
Je ne vois pas beaucoup d'anciens
ministres
en prison, en garde à vue, ou en...
[Sky] : T'en vois beaucoup prétendre à la fonction présidentielle, non ?
[Sky] : Ceux qui ont été condamnés avec beaucoup d'affaires, de détournements, ...
Mais tu vois...
[Sky] : ... de fraude à l'élection...
Hier, par exemple, sur les...
[Sky] : ... de financement des campagnes...
Hier sur les réseaux sociaux, tu as
un ancien procureur qui s'appelle
Philippe Bilger...
[Sky] : Qui a une chaîne YouTube, je crois bien.
OK
... qui criait au scandale...
Tu sais, c'est quand on crie au scandale par tweet !
Tu vois ce que je veux dire !
... qui criait au scandale en 140 signes
en s'interrogeant
sur les conditions dans lesquelles on
pouvait être
en face d'Alain Juppé quand on était
condamné pénalement.
[Sky] : Et réciproquement !
Moi je suis pas là pour, euh...
raviver des mauvais souvenirs chez tel ou tel.
Mais si on va sur le sujet des
condamnations pénales
sur un sujet Kerviel - Juppé,
enfin sauf à penser qu'il y a
des condamnations qui sont
[Sky] : plus légères que d'autres
plus
signifiantes que d'autres
ou plus légères que d'autres, tu vois, mais
j'avais l'impression que,
tu vois, qu'il y avait des espèces de trompettes de l'orchestre, là,
qui nous chantaient une musique qu'on connaît déjà très bien
et qu'on sait aujourd'hui décrypter.
Alors en 2012 quand je prenais la tête de la défense
pénale de Jérôme Kerviel tout ça
pouvait un peu
m'étonner, me questionner, m'interroger, tu vois, je pouvais me dire "Mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe ?". Mais là on en 2016,
mon client est responsable de 0,02 %
de la perte de Société Générale,
et en dépit de cette responsabilité
infinitésimale,
Société Générale est parvenue à
siphonner
2,2 milliards d'euros d'argent public !
Alors si on a postulé qu'on était en crise, nous, les français, on veut ce fric !
Et je te le dis comme ça : on veut ce
fric !
[Sky] : Maintenant.
Ben oui maintenant pourquoi plus tard ?
Il y a des intérêts sur tout ça, enfin tu vois.
Alors on te dit :
"On commandite des
rapports, des enquêtes, des trucs, des machins..."
Quand tu entends un politique te dire qu'il va faire une enquête,
monter une commission, ou
ou un machin comme ça, ça veut dire
que, en définitive,
et tu le sais très bien,
il ne fera rien !
Donc on doit muscler notre
attention, pour faire bien
attention à ce que
cet argent revienne dans la collectivité
nationale parce qu'il n'y a pas d'autre issue
légale possible.
Ou alors qu'on nous dise : "Bon ben quand c'est la banque, les gars,
c'est pas pareil !".
Et dans ce cas-là si nos concitoyens
sont d'accords,
j'ai pas de difficulté.
[Sky] : J'aimerais ouvrir une parenthèse et discuter avec toi
[Sky] : de l'état du monde,
[Sky] : comment tu perçois,
[Sky] : je vais te citer des mots, des sujets.
[Sky] :  Comme ça tu choisiras de t'engouffrer dans celui que tu veux.
[Sky] : L'élection américaine, Trump/Clinton, la Syrie,
[Sky] : les tensions avec la Russie,
[Sky] : Bachar el-Assad,
[Sky] : les frappes nucléaires préventives américaines,
[Sky] : les tensions avec l'OTAN,
[Sky] : la déstabilisation de la ceinture
méditerranéenne, les flux de migrants, les flux migratoires...
Alors, écoute, tu sais, je suis toujours mal à l'aise pour
pour discourir sur des sujets qui ne sont pas...
[Sky] : Tu n'es pas "les experts".
Oui ! Parce que
je me fous assez de la gueule
des experts autoproclamés,
qui publient...
[Sky] : Parle avec ton coeur en tant que citoyen !
un bouquin, tu vois,
aux Éditions de "la Pignole",
quand ça les intéresse de le
faire.
Donc je n'ai pas envie de verser dans ce défaut-là.
Mais, le point commun que je vois dans
tout ce que tu viens de citer, ce point
commun
c'est systématiquement la manière dont
le pouvoir et l'argent
sont traités et comment ils s'imbriquent.
Bon, on a quand même à peu près
tous compris
que la crise des migrants
qui est un drame humanitaire auquel
il m'est difficile
d'être insensible, et je n'ai pas la
volonté d'y être insensible mais
pourtant je n'ai pas de solution et
donc
je te le dis très clairement, mais on a
tous à peu près bien compris que
la déstabilisation au plan géopolitique de ce qui s'est passé
dans ces zones du monde
était la cause de ce qui est en train de
passer
de ce qui est en train de se passer
et je garde notamment à l'esprit un
discours de Kadhafi.
Alors je ne dis pas que je je regarde en
boucle les discours de Kadhafi. Mais
je me souviens qu'il disait : "Si je tombe,
vous serez
dans cette situation où des gens
déferleront sur vos côtes."
Je ne peux pas m'empêcher de voir
que c'est ce qui est en train de se passer.
Les raisons pour lesquelles on est parti
en Irak,
pour lesquelles avant ça on était en
Afghanistan,
pour lesquelles on est parti en Syrie,
pour lesquelles on a
fait ce qui s'est passé :
tu apprends systématiquement dix ans après
qu'il n'y a pas d'armes de destruction massive,
que, tu vois, donc...
[Sky] : Que la Lybie c'était pour des raisons personnelles,
[Sky] : des choses comme ça !
[Sky] : Je sais pas si tu as vu
[Sky] : c'est un papier d'un
canard en anglais
très connu qui disait que Sarkozy était parti en Lybie pour régler des affaires personnelles.
J'ai pas à prendre position là-dessus. Je connais et je lis
parce que je suis très assidu, tu vois, en terme de
consommation d'information, mais
je suis pas impliqué en tant
qu'avocat dans ces dossiers donc j'ai
pas envie de verser dans le...
J'ai envie...
[Sky]: Là on veut l'homme, on veut l'homme.
Ben je trouve que tout ça devrait
se regarder et que, à partir du moment où
la presse ou la justice prétendent que
ces raisons sont au centre
des décisions qui ont été prises, et qui nous étaient présentées comme étant des décisions quasiment humanitaires,
je pense que la justice devrait inscrire
au rang de ses priorités de nous dire,
et peut-être avant mai 2017,
si c'est le cas ou si c'est
et c'est peut-être ça, j'en sais rien,
si c'est une campagne de déstabilisation
de l'ancien président de la République Nicolas Sarkozy,
tu vois. Et moi je n'ai pas d'idée
parce que je n'ai pas d'éléments
et quand j'ai pas d'élément, je ne prends pas position.
[Sky] : Est-ce que tu connais
le budget de fonctionnement
[Sky] : du ministère de la Justice
français ?
Je crois, sans me tromper, qu'il est de 2 milliards ?
[Sky] : Et le budget de fonctionnement du ministère de l'écologie ?
Non, pas d'idée.
[Sky] : Alors d'après mes souvenirs, et je demanderai aux internautes de vérifier,
[Sky] : le budget de la justice en France est inférieur à celui de l'écologie.
Je ne crois pas qu'il faille comparer les deux, tu vois,
parce que, que le budget de l'écologie soit plus élevé que celui de la justice,
si celui de la justice n'est pas ridiculement bas,
je trouve ça, enfin tu vois.
L'écologie en tant que telle,
si on ne comprend pas aujourd'hui
qu'on est en train de mal se comporter
par rapport à notre écosystème,
il me semble qu'on loupe quelque chose
tu vois, sur la gestion de l'eau,
sur le...
il y a
d'autres sujets dont on a beaucoup parlé...
sur le...
Tu vois, l'élevage en batterie des animaux,
sur la manière dont ils sont abattus, sur...
Bon ça c'est pas un monde... et là tu ne m'interroges pas en tant qu'avocat,
[Sky] : Non, du tout.
ça, c'est pas un monde qui me convient et dans lequel
je vis sereinement. C'est la raison pour
laquelle je ne becte plus de viande depuis des...
[Sky] : D'ailleurs quelles sont tes mesures personnelles,
[Sky] : de tous les jours, pour essayer que le monde aille mieux ? Tu ne manges plus de viande ?
J'essaie de faire mon
job...
Non, ce n'est pas pour que le monde aille mieux,
c'est l'idée que tu te fais de...
ta participation dans ce
grand tout. Moi j'essaie de ne pas participer,
tu vois, à des schémas qui me semblent
inacceptables.
[Sky] : Lesquels?
Ben ça, je prenais pour exemple, par exemple,  le
fait de ne pas bouffer de viande.
Je n'ai pas envie de participer à ça.
J'avais lu, et je ne sais pas si c'est le cas ou pas, tu vois,
parce que je ne suis pas un spécialiste de cette matière,
qu'il faut 6000 litres d'eau
pour fabriquer 1 kg de boeuf.
Je ne peux pas m'empêcher de rapprocher de ça
des conséquences de la
sécheresse dans des continents
qui ne sont pas les nôtres
et je ne peux pas m'empêcher de me souvenir, que sur ces continents-là, dans ces continents-là,
il y a des gens qui meurent.
Quand tu n'as pas d'eau, tu ne cultives pas.
Quand tu ne cultives pas,
tu es obligé de chercher
à bouffer tous les jours.
Et quand t'es obligé de faire ça
tu ne peux pas t'éduquer !
Donc il me semble qu'il y a quand même une
volonté, là, de garder des clivages
Nord/Sud, de garder des... et ensuite il
ne faudra pas trop s'étonner si
ces gens-là ont envie d'avoir une vie meilleure !
Je ne trouve pas ça absurde !
[Sky] : C'est quoi ta plus grosse peur ?
Alors moi tu sais, je n'ai pas trop de...
Je mets pas souvent la trouille
dans mes équations de vie,
mais grosso modo ça serait de se mettre
à ressembler à ceux que nous combattons,
ça, ça ne me plairait pas.
Tu vois, on est encore dans des âges où on peut se dire :
"Oh, c'est des jeunes cons idéalistes !".
[Sky] : Quelle est ta plus grosse joie ?
Faire mon job...
Cette décision à 0,02 % tu vois, c'est une vraie joie !
Alors, j'ai lu quelques pisse-tiède qui disaient :
"Ah ben oui mais quand même Kerviel, 1 million d'euros,
il dit qu'il est satisfait", etc.
Oui, mais quand tu viens de 5 milliards d'euros
de condamnation,
tu vois ce que je veux dire !
Et si Société Générale a envie de
recouvrer ce million d'euros...
On l'invite même à le faire !
On en a presque besoin !
Pour la suite.
Parce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui dans une
équation, et on partage cette équation avec eux,
où plus ils taperont, et plus ils perdront !
Donc ça, tu vois, c'est une vraie joie !
Je ne te parle pas du recouvrement.
Je te parle de se dire que...
J'interviens au sein d'un cabinet :
le cabinet 28 octobre,
qui est un cabinet de
de gens courageux
et qui ont fait leur travail honnêtement
sans s'arrêter.
J'aime beaucoup cette idée.
[Sky] : Si on te proposait d'être ministre de la Justice un jour, tu accepterais ?
C'est complètement fictionnel ta question Sky !
[Sky] : C'est fictionnel, mais est-ce que tu accepterais ?
Je ne crois pas, non.
Je ne crois pas. Ça dépendra, j’imagine, de qui le proposera, et de quelle sera l'attitude.
Mais, tu vois, je ne crois pas qu'un ministre
puisse tout à la fois, s'occuper...
Tu sais, un ministre c'est comme
toi et moi, dans la vraie vie :
c'est-à-dire que c'est quelqu'un
qui doit dormir quelques heures,
qui doit se doucher,
qui doit manger,
qui peut avoir une vie de famille,
qui fait ce qu'il a à faire dans sa vie,
tu vois.
Et je ne pense pas qu'on puisse
s'occuper de la conduite pénale,
par exemple,
des affaires du pays,
et être en charge, également, des
dossiers judiciaires des anciens ministres,
des grands patrons,
de tout ce qui s'appelle
ces "dossiers signalés", là :
cette espèce d'écume qui fait que je pense
que c'est un plein temps pour eux
de les gérer.
Donc être ministre de la Justice,
de la Justice !
sans gérer les machins entre copains, oui,
si ce ministère-là existait,
mais je te le dis tout de go :
il n'existe pas.
Je trouverais intéressant de regarder ça.
Mais, moi, je ne vois pas, tu vois,
qui me le demanderait,
et pour quelles raisons j'accepterais par ailleurs.
[Sky] : Et qui tu verrais
à la place de notre ministre de la Justice ?
Je n'ai pas d’idée.
Dans cette organisation institutionnelle,
je n'ai pas d'idée.
On sait que le président de la République est le premier magistrat de France,
et on sait que les 2 derniers
n'ont pas rempli ce rôle-là.
[Sky] : C'est un euphémisme !
Tu vois, alors chef des armées quand ça les arrangeait, ça ils aiment bien le faire !
Mais je n'ai pas vu passer de mesures qui permettent de s'occuper de la politique pénale ou pénitentiaire du pays.
Quand tu vois nos chiffres sur les prisons,
quand tu vois l'état des prisons,
et je suis un avocat,
donc il m'arrive d'aller en prison,
tu dois faire un effort intellectuel,
pour te rappeler qu'on est en France !
[Sky] : C'est vraiment le tiers-monde ?
Mais c'est, c'est... Mais, enfin, il y a tout un tas de rapports qui sont publics.
[Sky] : On a été condamné, non ?
Mais bien sûr qu'on l'a été !
Nous n'avons de cesse que de l'être.
Il y a une plainte qui est déposée là,
parce qu'il y a des nuisibles dans les prisons,
il y a...
[Sky] : Surpopulation (inaudible)
On se dit ensuite que,
la prison,
tu vois, on a envie de vendre à la population française,
la prison comme étant un moyen de réinsertion.
C'est une mesure répressive,
mais on n'est pas censé sortir de prison
plus délinquant qu'on y est entré !
[Sky] : Ou plus radicalisé !
C'est un autre sujet,
mais il est cousin du sujet que j'évoque, effectivement.
Et là, en l’occurrence,
on voit mal comment on pourrait sortir de prison,
dans les conditions
qui sont les conditions de détention actuelles en France,
plus réinséré,
ou moins délinquant que ce qu'on y est entré.
[Sky] : Le fait que Manuel Valls souhaite construire une trentaine de prisons en plus,
[Sky] : et que les pays nordiques, eux, en ferment,
[Sky] : quelle est ta conclusion là-dessus ?
Si cette mesure émerge
dans les 6 derniers mois de mandat,
je n'ai pas grand-chose à t'en dire, en fait.
[Sky] :  (rire) Ouah t'es dur !
Mais non mais,
enfin tu vois, ce sont des gens qui sont là depuis 2012 au pouvoir !
[Sky] : Ils sculptent de la fumée encore ?
[Sky] : Ils brassent de l'air chaud ?
Je ne sais pas.
Il y a des intérêts qui me dépassent.
Moi je ne vois les choses
qu'en ma qualité d'avocat,
dans les dossiers qui sont les miens, Dieu merci, pas seulement le dossier Société Générale,
et je mesure les décalages entre la théorie et la pratique
trop souvent.
Et donc, ces espèces d'annonces politiques en fin de mandat, je sais pas.
[Sky] : Trump ou Clinton ?
Ni l'un, ni l'autre.
[Sky] : La peste ou le choléra ?
Ouais, écoute, je ne sais pas.Tout ça me...
J'ai toujours été fasciné
par cette capacité qu'avaient nos sociétés à fabriquer des familles de dirigeants !
On a ça chez les Kennedy.
Mais Kennedy, tu vois,
c'était les films couleur,
[Sky] : Les dynasties !
donc ça a quelque chose d'un peu exotique, d'un peu vintage.C'est pas mal, tu vois, ils avaient de la gueule !
Mais quand tu mets,
au prisme de ce que je suis en train de te dire,
la famille Hollande/Royal,
qu'est-ce qu'on est en train de nous dire ?
Que 2 personnes de la même promo de l'ENA,
- même promo ! -
qui partagent leurs vies,
qui sont dans le même courant politique,
peuvent être candidates en 2007 et
remporter l'élection en 2012.
On a eu ça avec Bush et Bush aux États-Unis, et maintenant Clinton, Bill Clinton, et Hillary Clinton.
Enfin, tu vois, ça me semble être une sorte d'OPA agressive
sur l'intérêt public.
J'ai du mal à croire, qu'à chaque fois,
les plus compétents
soient dans la même famille.
Ça m'émerveille un peu ça !
[Sky] : On a les politiques qu'on mérite ?
Ah oui, largement !
Oui, oui, largement ! Ça pour ça c'est très bien
la démocratie est parfaite pour ça !
[Sky] : Quelles solutions à ça ?
Tu sais, on en a déjà beaucoup parlé.
Moi je pense que ça passe par la justice.
Et je pense que,
sans justice indépendante,
il n'y a pas de démocratie.
J'ai eu déjà souvent l'occasion de
de le dire,
d'en parler,
de le développer,
mais
c'est un pilier
qui est indépassable.
Et, aujourd'hui,
la justice n'est pas indépendante !
Il faut que les gens qui nous regardent
le sachent, le mesurent, s'en inquiètent,
et se disent surtout que ça peut leur tomber dessus !
C'est terrifiant de se dire que
tu peux être pris
dans une mâchoire judiciaire.
Alors bon, quand tu y es pour quelque
chose...
Tu connais la loi,
tu la violes,
tu te fais attraper,
t'es puni...
[Sky] : T'assumes.
...ça c'est un sujet.
Mais quand on te met en travers,
pour des raisons qui te dépassent,
c'est hautement destructeur, en terme de vie.
Tu vois !
[Sky] : Qu'est-ce que tu penses,
[Sky] : un autre sujet,
[Sky] : du cas du général Piquemal
[Sky] : qui s'est fait radier
[Sky] : du cadre des armées pour avoir appelé à manifester ?
Je ne souhaite pas prendre position sur ces sujets
que je connais trop peu.
[Sky] : Quand, en France, si tu devais
voter
[Sky] : aux prochaines élections présidentielles,
Ouais...
[Sky] : tu voterais pour qui ?
Qui m'y forcerait ?
[Sky] : Moi !
Mais comment tu ferais ?
[Sky] : (rires) C'est compliqué !
[Sky] : Je te prends sur un ring, et je t'éclate !
(rires)
Non écoute, euh...
Je ne sais pas te répondre !
[Sky] : Tu soutiendrais personne ?
Si !
Je serais en mesure de soutenir des gens,
que j'estime être d'honnêtes personnes,
mais pas dans le système institutionnel
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui.
Parce que je ne pense pas
qu'ils seront en capacité de
de faire ce pour quoi ils sont là,
on les aura mis là, enfin vous les aurez mis là,
euh...
donc je...
[Sky] : Qu'est-ce que tu penses des civic tech ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
[Sky] : Les nouvelles plateformes pour que la démocratie s'exprime
Ah oui !
[Sky] : grâce au pouvoir numérique.
On est en train de regarder
un projet comme ça
avec des clients de mon cabinet.
Mais ils le disent en français, donc c'est pour ça que je ne savais pas ce que c'était.
[Sky] : Comment ils le disent ?
Ben des plateformes participatives, comme tu l'as dit
[Sky] : D'accord. (rires)
quand tu as arrêté de frimer et que tu m'as dit les choses normalement en fait !
[Sky] : Alors je ne frime pas : c'est le
thème du colloque de ce week-end
[Sky] : avec Axelle Lemaire sur les civic tech ! D'accord ? Donc je ne frime pas !
Ah mais c'est très bien,
si même Axelle Lemaire se met à...
[Sky] : On lui passe le bonjour d'ailleurs !
Très bien.
Ben ça fait
quelques années que je suis assez
émerveillé par la capacité
qu'on a à nous faire voter
s'agissant de tout un tas de
trucs
dont on n'a rigoureusement rien à
foutre !
Je te parle de programmes télé en tapant 1 ou 2
au 36-machin là,
sur nos portables, et où on n'a toujours pas
trouvé de moyen
de créer une application
numérique
permettant de faire des votations
comme les Suisses le fond.
Je ne dis pas qu'ils le font avec des applications numériques.
Mais on pourrait envisager
d'avoir une application
sur nos trop nombreuses tablettes qui peuplent
nos foyers, nos bureaux, nos trucs, nos machins,
pour dire : on arrête de vous donner à vous,
politiques,
des blancs-seings qui durent 5 années,
et sur les choses qui sont un peu
signifiantes, on vous consulte.
Et ça serait pas complètement idiot, je pense, que
de développer
ce type d'outil, tu vois, en ayant une plateforme unique, où,
voilà, le gouvernement va
consulter ses citoyens.
Je pense que nous irons vers cela !
[Sky] : Est-ce que tu penses que les citoyens
sont suffisamment aptes
à prendre leur destin en main ?
Ben ça dépend de la façon dont ils sont formés,
c'est tout le travail d'Alexandre Jardin, par exemple,
et de BBZ, de Bleu Blanc Zèbre,
sur l'éducation,
l'éducation au sens l'Éducation nationale, lire et faire lire,
enfin toutes ces associations, qui sont des associations absolument formidables,
dont l'objet est
de travailler sur
le degré de conscience
de nos concitoyens,
sur l'acquisition de leur vocabulaire...
Parce qu'en fait,
plus tu es con,
et plus tu es facile à rouler !
Et ça c'est un calcul
qui n'a échappé à personne !
[Sky] : Tu trouves qu'on est de plus en plus con
en ce moment ?
Je ne sais pas le quantifier. Je n'ai pas envie que tu m'amènes dans les cordes de "c'était mieux avant".
Mais...
je trouve qu'on a essayé et éculé tout un tas de systèmes, qui sont des systèmes perdants,
et qu'on est tout le temps en train d'essayer de les sauver, de les perfuser.
Alors qu'il y a des systèmes qui sont là, à nos portes,
et qu'on a suffisamment d'imagination
pour essayer de les bâtir
qui pourraient fonctionner de
manière un peu plus humaine
et un peu moins déconnante.
[Sky] : Tu serais prêt à monter une barricade ?
Ça dépend des intérêts en jeu,
mais, oui, oui, je n'ai pas de difficulté, oui.
[Sky] : Est-ce que tu penses qu'on est à la veille
de la nuit du 4 août ?
Non, je sais pas si on peut le dire comme ça, mais je pense
qu'on est à la veille d'un effondrement,
et on avait déjà discuté de ça, si ma mémoire est bonne,
qui sera un effondrement
civil ou un effondrement...
[Sky] : ...financier ?
Ouais !
[Sky] : Une implosion ?
Ben, tu sais, entre Noël et le jour de l'An dernier, en 2015,
nos chers politiques ont voté
une loi permettant
de piquer sur les comptes bancaires des Français, tout ce qui est au-dessus de 100 000 €
pour sauver des banques qui sont en
faillite.
De la même manière, Michel Sapin, pendant que les journalistes étaient en vacances, a nommé comme directeur de cabinet,
à Bercy, son cabinet,
un monsieur qui s'appelle Thierry Aulagnon,
qui était le patron de la banque
d'investissement de Société Générale !
[Sky] : C'est beau !
Il y a quand même un peu...Il y a un sujet tu vois !
[Sky] : Ah c'est beau !
parce que le sujet des 2,2 milliards, il n'est pas nouveau !
Donc je n'accuse pas ces gens
de faire des conflits d'intérêt, je te dis simplement que
va exister un moment où
tout ça va se voir !
Et donc là, on continuera
d'être posés comme des gros culs devant TF1
en train de regarder je ne sais pas quoi.
Moi j'ai pas la télé, donc je ne peux pas nourrir mon exemple, mais...
Ou on va prendre destin du pays en mains,
quand je dis "on" c'est nos concitoyens, tu vois,
et on fera les choses telles
qu'elles doivent être faites !
Et je pense qu'on verra ça de notre vivant,
nous, là, les gens qui sont dans cette pièce.
Je pense que c'est notre génération
qui fera ce chemin.
[Sky] : Ou le subir !
Bah, c'est à nous de décider, oui !
[Sky] : Tu penses que la Presse...
[Sky] : ...qu'il reste une presse libre en France ?
Ben, elle est amusante ta question, parce que
ma présence ici,
alors que nous sommes invités partout,
Jérôme Kerviel et moi,
est une forme de réponse !
Me semble-t-il.
C'est-à-dire que,
tu vois, trouver un média
où tu as de la place,
où tu as du temps,
où tu n'es pas censuré,
[Sky] : tronqué, travesti...
Alors il y a des journaux qui font de l'investigation, qui font ça très bien, mais ils n'ont pas ce genre de format.
Et puis de manière générale,
tu sais très bien quelle est ma position sur le sujet.
Quand tu regardes dans des canards,
divers et variés,
un papier sur l'affaire dite Kerviel,
et que la page d'à côté
c'est une publicité en quadrichromie pour la
Société Générale,
tu comprends très bien que,
toi,
tu es un fait divers d'actualité,
et que tu n'es pas un annonceur,
parce que tu n'es pas totalement débile,
donc tu comprends très bien qu'il y en a un qui n'a pas payé : c'est toi,
et qu'il y en a un qui a payé : c'est pas toi !
Tu vois, avec une maquette et de la publicité, donc
la presse qui se fabrique,
et ce modèle économique,
il existe depuis longtemps,
je n'ai pas de sujet,
mais il faut simplement être très vigilant :
la presse qui se fabrique
au moyen de financements publicitaires,
est une presse qu'on doit
lire avec une attention plus,
et un recul un peu plus,
un peu plus accrus.
Par exemple, sur Mediapart,
ou sur Bakchich à l'époque, ou sur Les Jours, ou
[Sky] : Arrêt sur Images ?
Bon, euh...
oui, oui, oui,
Arrêt sur Images, oui.
Mais quand tu n'as pas d'annonceur,
on est sur quelque chose de plus direct quoi.
La courroie de transmission entre
la fabrication du produit et la manière
dont l'information te parvient,
est plus courte.
[Sky] : Deux dernières questions :
[Sky] : Déjà la première :
Est-ce que tu as des questions à nous poser ?
[Sky] : et la dernière :
Laisse un conseil aux jeunes générations.
Oui, j'ai une question à te poser, c'est :
Allez-vous nous inviter tous les deux mois,
comme on est en train de le faire là ?
Parce qu'il faut que j'organise mon agenda !
(rires)
[Sky] : C'était exceptionnel !
Là, déjà, on avait envie de te revoir, parce que
[Sky] : on a fait une bonne interview, et on avait bien discuté,
[Sky] : et bon on peut se voir dans le privé, mais la
communauté nous a réclamé...
C'était une question pour rire, en vrai, hein !
[Sky] : Ouais ! (soulagement)
Non, non, entre les questions que j'ai à te poser, tu sais très bien quelles sont les questions que j'ai à te poser,
elles sont évidemment hors cam',
[Sky] : Exact !
et je ne vais pas m'en priver
dans quelques minutes là !
[Sky] : Avec plaisir !
Pour faire avancer les sujets qui nous tiennent à cœur.
Les jeunes générations,
ben les jeunes générations voilà ça y est :
tu me fous dans la
dans la position du gars qui doit donner
des conseils aux jeunes générations,
c'est la première fois que ça m'arrive,
je ne te remercie pas pour ça !
Oui, ben écoute, moi j'ai envie de leur dire
de ne pas voter en fait !
Et de dire haut et fort
pourquoi ils ne participent pas à ça.
Et si le message n'est pas assez clair,
je pense qu'il y a un conseil qui tient au soulèvement.
Parce qu'on doit mettre un terme à
ce qui est en train de se passer,
en terme de
de mainmise de la Finance sur la Justice.
Et
je vois tout de suite les tweets,
tu vois, dans cet espèce d'écran mental qui est le mien,
une sorte de machin, un hologramme,
qui est entre toi et moi.
Des tweets de : "Oh le complot !"
"La théorie du complot !" Et cætera.
Non, non, on vous parle de faits en fait !
On vous parle de faits !
Et il y a un super programme à mettre en œuvre, et auquel les gens qui nous regardent,
et notamment les jeunes,
puisque c'est à eux que tu me demandes de m'adresser, de réfléchir,
C'est...Il est tout simple et totalement révolutionnaire puisque ça n'a jamais été fait :
Application de la loi aux banques !
Application de la loi aux politiques !
Nos lois sont bien en vrai !
Je t'assure que nos lois sont bien !
C'est-à-dire, je les manie au quotidien,
c'est mon boulot, tu vois.
Elles sont très bien
quand elles sont appliquées,
à tout le monde,
et ça, c'est la définition d'une démocratie,
et quand ça, ça sera fait,
ben on pourra tous aller voter tranquillement.
En attendant je pense qu'il faut faire la grève du vote !
[Sky] : David Koubbi, merci !
Merci Sky !
(Musique du générique de fin...)